your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
your excellencies dear laureates ladies
and gentlemen it is my honor to
represent the Nobel Prize in Physics
2018 and speak on behalf of Arthur
Ashkan and Gerrard Marui my esteemed
colleagues with whom I share the prize
Arthur Ashe can one-half of it this year
and so he should be the one giving this
speech unfortunately he could not join
us for this incredible celebration
Gerard and I want to add our
congratulations to Arthur for his
remarkable invention of laser tweezers
that can trap living cells and wind up
molecular motors we wish Arthur could be
here as has been pointed out I joined
Marie Curie and Maria gape admire as the
only women to win this prize I am
humbled to be in their company Marie
Curie is in a class all her own as the
first female winner and still the only
person to win the Nobel Prize in two
different science categories an
astounding scientist for her PhD maria
cape admired absolutely
Maria gave admirer a theoretical
physicist came up with the idea of multi
photon physics that means an atom
absorbs two or more photons
simultaneously
she made the prediction without any
experimental evidence and in fact it
would be another 30 years before I
didn't want to observe the effect I
cited her theory in my PhD thesis more
than fifty years later and as for me
when I was in grad school working on the
project for which Gerard and I are being
honored cyndi lauper
had a big hit girls just want to have
fun but they wanted to wait until the
working day is done but I want to have
fun while I'm working now not everyone
thinks physics is fun but I do
I think experimental physics is
especially fun because not only do you
get to solve puzzles about the universe
or here on earth there are really cool
toys in the lab in my case I get to play
with high intensity lasers that can do
magical things like take one color of
laser light and turn it into a rainbow
of colors just one of the amazing things
we get to see in our laser labs Jordan
aru there was my PhD supervisor dreamed
up the idea of increasing laser
intensity by orders of magnitude he did
it while he was on a ski trip with his
family he probably shouldn't have been
thinking about lasers he just couldn't
help himself it was my job to take sure
our beautiful idea and make it a reality
I built a pulse stretcher then a laser
amplifier and then finally a pulse
compressor to do so I had to learn to
cleave optical fiber machine a lot of
parts do a lot of plumbing are you
feeling the fun
I had to measure the pulse durations and
the frequency spectrum not all of the
measurements show what we expected we
had to figure out the problems and then
away around them that was the fun part
that all took about a year then it was
finally time to measure the duration of
the compressed amplified pulses and I
had no way to measure it
Steve Williamson my colleague had the
way and he wheeled history camera into
my lab one night and together we
measured the compressed pulse width of
the amplified pulses I will never forget
that night it is truly an amazing
feeling when you know that you have
built something that no one else ever
has and it actually works there really
is no excitement quite like it
except for maybe getting woken up at
5:00 in the morning because the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences also thinks
it was an exciting moment for the field
of laser physics
so on behalf of Arthur askin sure our
booth and me thank you to the Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences and the
Nobel foundation for honoring us and
laser physics with this Nobel Prize
[Applause]